rolle rückwärts nach nur 24 stunden
thomas kemmerich der neue fdp
ministerpräsident in thüringen gibt sein
amt auf
damit möchten wir neuwahlen herbeiführen
um damit den makel der unterstützung
durch die afw vom amt des
ministerpräsidenten zu nehmen was
dahinter ringen passiert hat ein
politisches beben ausgelöst weit über
erfurt hinaus die nachrichten nicht an
das heute mit christian sievers guten
abend in allen an diesem donnerstag es
ist viel passiert den sport haben wir
aber auch natürlich mit sven voss auch
von mir einen schönen genommen die
politischen verwerfungen in thüringen
halten auch die bundespolitik in atem
heute morgen spricht thomas kemmerich
neuer ministerpräsident von thüringen
noch davon sich an die arbeit machen zu
wollen
am nachmittag kündigte er an er werde
sein amt zur verfügung stellen
kemmerich war gestern nicht nur mit den
stimmen seiner fdp sondern auch von cdu
und fdp wählt wurden
er will jetzt dass es neuwahlen gibt
zuvor war fdp chef christian lindner
extra nach erfurt gekommen
weiteres zeichen dafür wie viel unruhe
diese wahl auch bundesweit auslöst wir
beginnen heute abend in thüringen mit
beate türen einen tag nach seiner
überraschenden und umstrittenen wahl zum
thüringer ministerpräsidenten und kurz
nach dem treffen mit seinem parteichef
kündigt thomas kemmerich also nun seinen
rücktritt an
zusammen mit meinen kollegen der
landtagsfraktion der freien demokraten
haben wir beschlossen die auflösung des
thüringer landtages zu beantragen
damit möchten wir neuwahlen herbeiführen
um damit den makel der unterstützung
durch die afd
vom amt des ministerpräsidenten zu
nehmen
am späten nachmittag ziehen wieder
etliche hundert thüringer durch erfurt
um noch einmal gegen die wahl von
kemmerich zu demonstrieren
trotzdem das land ist gespalten er
wollte ja gewählt und man sollte sich
einfach nach demokratischen partei dpj
war sollte man sich so stellen wie sie
jetzt vielleicht müsste sich die mit ihr
zusammen tun und vielleicht auch mal
weniger eigene ideologie sich irgendwo
positionieren ansonsten würde ich da gar
keinen ausweg sehen und ich kann mir
auch vorstellen dass es nach den
neuwahlen wieder neuwahlen geben würde
wie es weitergeht den thüringen
beschäftigt schon den ganzen tag die
fraktionen im landtag auch hier gibt es
unterschiedliche auffassungen
wir wollen verantwortung übernehmen das
gilt für rot-rot-grün das geht für uns
als linke das geht für bodo ramelow
thomas kemmerich muss den weg frei
machen und da gibt es keine halben
sachen sondern muss zurücktreten und im
parlament die vertrauensfrage stellen er
soll eine auflösung des landtags bringen
eine neue wahl neuer verhältnisse werden
sich daraus nicht wirklich ergeben die
die fdp wird wahrscheinlich aus dem
landtag fliegen die cdu wird federn
lassen
fdp und linke werden gewinnen bei den
grün weiß man nicht ob sie da rein kommt
der angekündigte rückzug des gerade mal
einen tag alten ministerpräsidenten hat
thüringen also erneut mächtig gerüttelt
am abend trifft sich die cdu
landtagsfraktion und will entscheiden ob
sie neuwahlen mit tret und auch die
cdu-chefin aus berlin ist mit dabei für
uns beobachtet dass michael bewerunge
live in erfurt michael wie geht es jetzt
weiter ziehen denn da alle mit bei einer
auflösung des landtags
ja ich würde mal sagen das wird ziemlich
kompliziert hier im thüringischen
landtag hinter mir herr kemmerich hat
zwar von rücktritt gesprochen aber hat
ihn noch nicht ausgesprochen und selbst
das tut dann bliebe er geschäftsführend
im amt bis zu neuwahlen
die villa beantragen aber braucht die
stimmen eine zweidrittelmehrheit im
landtag von fdp und cdu beide fraktionen
haben bisher keine bereitschaft
neuwahlen erkennen lassen im moment
kommt gerade die cdu fraktion hinter mir
zu einer art krisensitzung zusammen
dazu wird auch die bundesvorsitzende
kramp karrenbauer aus berlin erwartet
gegen halb neun soll ist ein statement
geben da wissen wir mehr
kemmerich hat jedenfalls angekündigt nur
wenn es keine neuwahlen gibt dann wieder
die vertrauensfrage stellen und sich
einem konstruktiven misstrauensvotum
stellen bodo ramelow hat schon gesagt
dann würde auch wieder kandidiert wie
kommt das jetzt in thüringen an michael
ein ministerpräsident der sich in seiner
aussage einmal komplett dreht und jetzt
dann doch gehen will
wir haben das gerade schon in den roten
gehört das land ist gespalten es gibt
eine fraktion gesagt moment mal das war
doch ein ganz demokratischer vorgang
hier ist eine art meinungs- kartell am
werk das außerhalb der demokratischen
regeln die afg von der macht ab halten
will und die anderen sagen moment die
afg hat die mast machtmissbrauch in dem
sie nur einen schein kandidaten
aufgestellt hat und hatte nur ein
machtspielchen spielen wollen verwirrung
stiften wollen fdp und union haben diese
spieler links mitgespielt und den
scherbenhaufen heute aufzuwischen das
ist heute sicherlich nicht ganz gelungen
michael vielen dank das beben von
thüringen wirkt in berlin nach und wie
der fdp-bundesvorsitzende christian
lindner will in seinem parteivorstand
die vertrauensfrage stellen
es gibt auch in der fdp massive kritik
an der art wie sich ihr parteifreund in
thüringen hat wählen lassen und es gibt
drängende fragen an lindner
krisensitzung auch bei der cdu die liegt
mit ihrem thüringischen landesverband
über kreuz auch die dortige cdu hatte ja
den neuen ministerpräsidenten mitgewählt
eine wahl die bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel heute als unverzeihlich
bezeichnet mathis feldhoff
es ist eine ansage aus dem ausland auf
ihrer südafrika-reise verurteilt angela
merkel die vorgänge in thüringen das
besondere sie macht es von sich aus ohne
von journalisten gefragt zu werden da
dies absehbar war
in der kunst des konstellation wie im
dritten wahlgang gewählt wurde muss man
sagen dass dieser vorgang unverzeihlich
ist und deshalb auch das ergebnis wieder
rückgängig gemacht werden muss für die
ard war es eine ganz normale wahl die
einmischung der kanzlerin sei völlig
überzogen wie so ein solches ergebnis zu
rückgängig gemacht werden muss von der
bundeskanzlerin ist mir
demokratietheoretisch nicht begreifbar
gestern noch hatte christian lindner für
seinen ministerpräsidenten der mitte
geworben es folgte ein proteststurm
außerhalb und innerhalb der fdp
heute reist der fdp-chef extra nach
thüringen um seinen ministerpräsidenten
wieder aus dem amt zu drängen die
kehrtwende zu kandidieren ist legitim
aber es ist eben nicht möglich bei jedem
zustandekommen einer wahl an amt
auszügen im hamburger wahlkampf
überklebt die fdp unterdessen plakate
mit dem die mitte lebt slogan was für
eine riesen großer schaden ist nicht nur
für unsere partei damit sondern
natürlich aufenthalt demokratie
angerichtet waren in berlin versucht die
cdu verzweifelt die thüringischen
parteifreunde auf ihre linie zu zwingen
und auch der koalitionspartner will
reden allerdings darüber was die
cdu-spitze wusste hier reden wir über
eine gefährdung der demokratie in
deutschland mit auswirkungen auch auf
den ruf unseres landes über die grenzen
deutschlands hinweg thüringen braucht
jetzt einen neustart dieser neustart
kann für die cdu nur auf grundlage der
beschlüsse des parteitages der cdu
deutschlands erfolgen
reden werden sie am samstag auf dem
krisengipfel im kanzleramt
und auch wir haben viel zu besprechen
jetzt mit meiner kollegin sharon terlep
energy in berlin
catala zuerst wie angeschlagen sind die
parteichefs von
fdp und cdu jetzt sehr muss man sagen
und das gilt für beide annegret kramp
karrenbauer war zwar sehr klar und
deutlich in ihren ansagen und in ihrem
vorgaben gestern aber das hätte sich
schon längst vorher machen können und
hätte sie das getan während die cdu
vielleicht überhaupt nicht in dieser
situation es stellt sich also die
führungsfrage nämlich die frage wer
bestimmt eigentlich die richtung in der
cdu annegret kramp karrenbauer mit ihrem
annäherungs und kooperationsverbot dass
die partei geschlossen hat oder doch
andere kräfte in der partei und
christian lindner muss jetzt in die
vorwärtsverteidigung und muss die
vertrauensfrage stellen um die kritiker
in seiner eigenen partei still zu
stellen und um den deckel wieder auf den
topf zu kriegen voller fragen vor allem
der frage welche rolle er bei diesem
ganzen vorgang gespielt hat und dann
kommt man auf das große bild ganz
deutschland guckt jetzt auf die
einmalige situation dass da ein
ministerpräsident gewählt wird und die
eigene partei ihn danach auffordert
zurückzutreten
wie viel schaden hinterlässt diese wahl
in der deutschen demokratie das kann man
wahrscheinlich nicht genau beziffern
aber der schaden ist da und er trifft
alle parteien die einen weil sie die
bühne geboten haben mit dem versuch eine
minderheitsregierung wählen zu lassen
dort in unsicheren verhältnissen und die
anderen weil sie diese bühne genutzt
haben in der denkbar schlechtesten weise
weil sie taktiert haben weil sie gegen
politische gepflogenheiten verstoßen
haben das ist genau die art von politik
die zur verdrossenheit führt und die
vertrauen untergräbt und glaubwürdigkeit
und verlässlichkeit sind nunmal hohe
güter in der demokratie beides haben
alle beteiligten parteien aufs spiel
gesetzt und sind dabei nicht gut
rausgekommen aus diesem spiel
das wird sicherlich noch lange
nachhallen herzlichen dank nach berlin
polit chaos in thüringen zerreißprobe
für die demokratie fragezeichen es gibt
ein zdf spezial gleich nach uns hier und
auch online auf heute.de haben wir alle
wichtigen informationen zu diesem thema
zusammengefasst etwa wie realistisch
jetzt neuwahlen sind in thüringen so
viel zunächst dazu
in den usa ist das
amtsenthebungsverfahren vorbei und der
sieger heisst donald trump der senat
sprach den präsidenten mit der mehrheit
der republikaner frei ihm war im
zusammenhang mit der sogenannten
karine affäre machtmissbrauch und
behinderung des kongresses vorgeworfen
worden
trump feiert den freispruch heute als
sieg des landes über den so sagt er
wörtlich impeachment scherz eine woche
nachdem die usa ihre nahost plan
vorgestellt haben flammt der konflikt
zwischen israel und den palästinensern
neu auf in jerusalem vor ein attentäter
mit einem auto in eine gruppe soldaten
14 menschen wurden verletzt
in der altstadt von jerusalem erschossen
polizisten ein palästinenser der einen
beamten mit schüssen verletzt hatte im
westjordanland gab es bei zusammenstößen
mit israelischen soldaten nach
palästinensischen angaben zwei tote
lasst julian assange frei das ist der
appell heute aus deutschland
unterschrieben von politikern künstlern
und journalisten die schwere vorwürfe
erheben richtung schweden großbritannien
usa
der hintergrund seit april sitzt
wikileaks gründer assange in einem
britischen gefängnis der vorwurf er sei
dort psychischer folter ausgesetzt
die usa fordern seine auslieferung sie
sind seit zehn jahren hinter ihm her
denn 2010 hatte assange auf seiner
plattform geheime dokumente zum irak
krieg veröffentlicht hoch brisant weil
es um amerikanische kriegsverbrechen
ging jetzt sagte ein uno ermittlern
assange werde ein exempel statuiert um
nachahmer einzuschüchtern bernd benthin
in berlin tritt heute vormittag eine
ungewöhnliche gruppe vor die presse ein
journalist ein ex spd außenminister ein
ex fdp innenminister und eine
politikerin der linken gemeinsames
anliegen last assange frei kann man
einem liebesverhältnis
natürlich kann man das er hat ist selbst
sozusagen ein borderliner in vielen
fragen aber gerade dann muss der
rechtsstaat zeigen dass er seinen
prinzipien einhält und das ist erkennbar
nicht der fall
aus angst vor einer auslieferung
verschanzt sich der wikileaks-gründer
sieben jahre lang in der botschaft
ecuadors in london im april 2009 10 wird
er verhaftet wartet seitdem auf seinen
prozess
der un sonderberichterstatter nils
melzer untersucht den fall und spricht
im zdf-interview von psychischer folter
an assange und von erheblichen
rechtsstaat
welchen mängeln schwedische verhör akten
seien gefälscht worden
außerdem hätte assange nicht die chance
gehabt sich zu verteidigen immer mal ein
bisschen an der oberfläche kratzt dann
kommen die widersprüche sofort zum
vorschein und sie tiefer man rein kommt
desto schmutziger wird es dem aufruf
assange freizulassen schließen sich in
deutschland mehr als 130 künstler
medienschaffende und politiker an julian
assange hat sich körperlich sehr stark
verändert er hat unter der isolation
quasi in der ecuadorianischen botschaft
in london gelitten er hat gelitten unter
neun monaten isolationshaft in einem
hochsicherheitsgefängnis wir wollen
julian assange unterstützen und damit
eine bankrotterklärung westlicher
rechtstaatlichkeit verhindert ende des
monats soll das auslieferungsverfahren
gegen assange beginnen in den usa droht
ihm eine haftstrafe von bis zu 175
jahren in deutschland gibt es einen
weiteren corona virus fall
es handelt sich um die frau eines
infizierten aus bayern damit steigt die
zahl der betroffenen auf 13 auf einem
kreuzfahrtschiff in japan verdoppelte
sich die zahl der infizierten auf 20 das
schiff steht unter quarantäne
nur zehn neue infizierte dürften zur
behandlung das schiff verlassen
auch in hongkong stecken tausende auf
einem kreuzfahrtschiff fest
kirk douglas weiter der letzten des
goldenen zeitalters im kino jetzt ist er
im hohen alter von 103 jahren gestorben
sein sohn michael schreibt dazu auf
instagram für die welt war er eine
legende aber für mich und meine brüder
war einfach nur papier auch andere
hollywood größen würdigten charakter
glass unter anderem der star-regisseur
steven spielberg kirk bewahrte bis zum
ende seines wundervollen lebens das
charisma eines filmstars daran erinnert
oliver flammen es war sein
charakteristisches grübchen am kinn und
sein unwiderstehliches lächeln wo für
ihn vor allem seine weiblichen fans
liebten
schon ende der 1940 er jahre war köllges
in den usa
star mit hauptrollen in die wikinger und
spartacus wird der durchtrainierte da
geht's auch international berühmt vor
allem weil er auch tragische gebrochene
helden überzeugend spielen kann wie etwa
den künstler vincent van gogh ihr denkt
ich habe immer nur mit john wayne
pistolen spielchen gespielt aber das
stimmt nicht ich bin ein romantischer
typ und ein politischer kopf in der
mccarthy-ära unterstützt kolb tacheles
künstler unter kommunismus verdacht und
riskiert damit seine eigene karriere für
sein lebenswerk bekommt er 1996 den
oscar da ist es schon 80 jahre alt von
einem schweren schlaganfall lässt er
sich nicht unterkriegen und behält
seinen humor auch dank der liebevollen
hilfe seiner zweiten frau mit der er
über 60 jahre verheiratet ist manchmal
beschwert er sich viel an einem tag ist
es die schulter am nächsten es ist der
rücken dann der kopf liebling du
zerstörst mein image
er ist schon 102 jahre alt und trotzdem
dabei als sein sohn michael seinen stern
in hollywood bekommt aus ganzem herzen
ich bin so stolz dein sohn zu sein
angst vor dem tod hatte kolb der isny
103 jahre was für ein leben das kann man
so sagen
jetzt kommt der sport mit einer
überraschenden personalie im deutschen
handball
christian prokop ist nicht mehr länger
bundestrainer das gab der deutsche
handballbund vor zwei stunden bekannt
nachfolger wird der frühere kieler
erfolgstrainer alfred gislason
gerüchte gab es schon während der em nun
muss er gehen weil man ihm das erreichen
der kurzfristigen ziele nicht mehr
zutraut wir haben diese schwere
entscheidung nach reiflicher abwägung
und einer ganzheitlichen analyse aus
verantwortung für den deutschen handball
getroffen so präsident andreas
michelmann programms mannschaft hatte
von sieben spielen nur die beiden gegen
die späteren finalisten verloren platz
fünf und nicht nur seine spieler
sprachen offen das vertrauen aus
auch das verhältnis gut und jeden fall
auch nun also ein sinneswandel auch weil
ein erfolgscoach übernehmen kann
dem isländer alfred gislasson elf jahre
trainer beim thw kiel trauen die
verantwortlichen die qualifikation für
olympia zu zum fussball der fc bayern
münchen steht dem dfb pokal
viertelfinale gegen hoffenheim führte
der titelverteidiger schon deutlich mit
4 zu 1 zeigte dann aber erstaunliche
schwächen
mit der auswechslung von thomas müller
und robert lewandowski war der schwung
der bayern endgültig dahin
die beiden hatten an allen toren zur 4
1-führung wesentlichen anteil letzten
zehn minuten bundes zum unerwünschten
nervenkitzel für die münchner das war
dann auch fatal dass wir es nicht
geschafft haben den gegner so unter
druck zu setzen dass sie dann die räume
bekommen haben einfach und dass wir dann
immer einen schritt zu spät waren
riskante pässe fehlen das pressing und
spiel ohne ball die hauptgründe warum
der bis dahin brave gegner nochmal ins
spiel kam war brachte hoffenheim doch
bis auf 3 4 heran
und das hatten wir schon mainz hat sie
das schon ein bisschen angedeutet in der
zweiten halbzeit heute wieder das davon
passion gegen den bundesliga-rivalen aus
leipzig am sonntag können sich die
bayern der leyen nachlässigkeit wohl
nicht leisten
außerdem gewannen leverkusen 2 1 gegen
den vfb stuttgart 4
ist es zufall verliert 0 zu 1 gegen
union berlin
die einzigen amateure im viertelfinale
kommen vom fc saarbrücken
matchwinner gegen karlsruhe daniel bax
der torwart hält im elfmeterschießen
anschließend sorgt christopher schorch
für den 5 3-endstand saarbrücken damit
seit 35 jahren erstmals wieder im dfb
pokal viertelfinale
das war es vom sport christian slater
vielberg und der hat noch einen
außerirdischen rekord zum schluss fast
elf monate war die us astronautin
christina coach im all so lange wie noch
keine frau vor
zusammen mit zwei ss kollegen ist sie
heute sicher und glücklich in kasachstan
gelandet
tests sollen jetzt zeigen welche
auswirkung die langzeit raumfahrt auf
eine frau hat das ist vorbereitung auf
das mars und mond programm der nasa auf
der erde in der zwischen 23
das winterwetter aber der nächste sturm
deutet sich schon an sagt gleich katja
hall war das heute journal mit der
kollegin marietta slomka und die hat
fragen an fdp chef christian lindner ab
21 uhr 55 zum thema thüringen und die
folgen auch das zdf spezial jetzt gleich
mit matthias fornoff von uns allen in
allen einen angenehmen abend und das
morgen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren ruhiges
hochdruckwetter das bedeutet die
hochwasser situation zum beispiel an der
donau oder auch im westen deutschlands
entspannt sich zusehends bedeutet
allerdings auch relativen langweilige
dichte wolken über der mitte und im
norden deutschlands die heute kaum mal
die sonne durch schließen
sie brachten sogar ein bisschen
nieselregen oder schneegriesel
heute nacht allerdings sind diese wolken
meist ohne schnee krise und diesel regen
unterwegs richtung südwesten funkeln die
sterne
je nachdem ob sie die sterne sehen
können oder ob die wolkendecke über
ihnen dicht ist ist die temperatur ganz
unterschiedlich unter den grauen wolken
bleibt es mild bei 6 bis 3 grad unter
dem klaren sternenhimmel sinken die
werte am alpenrand über schnee aber bis
minus zehn grad und morgen liegen dann
die höchsttemperaturen zwischen 3 grad
hier rund um hof und 10 grad rundum
emmerich am wetter ändert sich nicht so
sehr viel es gibt dichtere wolken im
nordosten vor allen dingen zwischen der
elbe und im spreewald an der küste kommt
die sonne zum vorschein aber richtung
südwesten
da scheint die sonne richtig satt und
richtig schönes wetter gibt's auch noch
mal am samstag ankommen allerdings schon
regenschauer von nordwesten heran
der sonntag wird schon stürmisch und in
der nacht auf montag droht bei uns ein
orkan
schönen abend noch